There is a crisis happening here
along the border of Belarus and Poland.
Thousands of migrants trying
to make it deeper into Europe
had been trapped in makeshift camps
in freezing temperatures for weeks.
Often without water, food,
or medical attention.
"Thousands of people caught in the middle of
an intensifying geopolitical dispute."
"Stranded in freezing conditions."
"Human rights groups say that the harsh conditions
have already killed some of the migrants."
Migrants coming to Europe usually
make their way through countries
that border the Mediterranean sea.
But earlier this year, Poland, Lithuania,
and Latvia saw a spike
in irregular crossings along
their landlocked borders.
When you take a closer look
you'll notice these crossings are taking place
along Belarus' entire border with the EU.
And the reason this border is the new epicenter
of Europe’s migration crisis
is one man.
Europe’s last dictator.
In 2020, Alexander Lukashenko, claimed victory
in Belarus’ presidential election.
An election widely believed to be rigged.
Backed by his main ally Russia,
Lukashenko ruled for four prior terms
that were also considered fraudulent.
But this time the response was different.
After the results were announced, thousands
of Belarusians took to the streets,
despite the pandemic, to demand
Lukashenko step down.
Instead, he responded with a brutal crackdown
and arrested more than 7,000 protesters.
Hundreds were beaten and tortured.
Four people died.
And his political opposition
was forced to flee the country.
Lukashenko’s nickname, “Europe’s last dictator”
became more fitting than ever.
The EU responded with sanctions,
marking the beginning of a dangerous struggle
between the EU and Belarus.
“The EU will impose sanctions on a substantial
number of individuals responsible for violence,
repression, and election fraud."
Despite this first round of sanctions
Lukashenko continued to crush dissent.
He used prisons across the country
to hold hundreds of political prisoners.
And arrested 27,000 civilians.
So, the EU doubled down and imposed
two more rounds of sanctions.
But Lukashenko only got more aggressive.
In May of 2021, Belarus intercepted
a passenger plane
as it flew over Belarus’ airspace.
After forcing it to land,
Belarus officials arrested
a prominent Belarusian opposition journalist.
He was allegedly forced to confess
to plotting riots on camera.
As of today, he is still under house arrest.
The EU countered with yet another
round of sanctions.
This time, Lukashenko manufactured
a crisis at the border
to get back at them.
Migrants hoping to get to Europe often make
their way to these coastal areas
and then take a dangerous boat ride
to European shores.
It’s an arduous journey that can take days.
Many don’t make it.
But in the summer of 2021, a seemingly easier
path opened up.
Shortly after the fourth round of EU sanctions,
Lukashenko announced:
He wouldn't be stopping migrants
from heading to the EU.
It was more than just a warning.
Belarus hadn’t seen a lot of Middle Eastern
migrants come through here in the past.
So the Lukashenko regime created new ways
to lure them into the country.
Belarus began offering tourist visas to thousands
in the Middle East.
Especially in Iraq.
Flights from Istanbul, Damascus and Dubai
on Belavia, Belarus’ state-owned airline,
more than doubled compared to
the same time last year.
Encouraged by Belarus' open borders,
thousands of migrants from war-torn zones
arrived in Minsk.
Once on the ground, reports show
Belarusian guards
bussed them to the border along
Latvia, Lithuania, and Poland.
But the EU border wasn’t open to them.
All three countries declared a state of emergency
at the border and put up barbed wire fences.
Looking for an opening, thousands of migrants
eventually ended up here,
at this checkpoint on the border
where things escalated.
Poland rushed thousands of troops to the border
to push the migrants back.
They used tear gas and water canons
to stop migrants from crossing.
On the Belarusian side, border guards
wouldn’t let the migrants retreat.
They forcibly held them and
pushed them to try again.
As many as 4,000 migrants got trapped
in this violent cycle.
They couldn't go back to their home countries
and couldn't go to Minsk either.
Those tourist visas were no longer
available to them.
The EU labeled this “hybrid warfare”.
And in many ways, it is an act of aggression.
Belarus trapped the migrants.
But the EU also failed the migrants
by ignoring its own legal code
which prohibits collective expulsions,
or pushbacks
and guarantees “minimum rights [for] persons
apprehended or intercepted in connection with
irregular border crossings.”
Contrary to the law, the migrants here
were denied their rights and pushed away.
And it’s not the first time it’s happened.
In 2015 Syria, Iraq, and other Middle Eastern
countries were deep in conflict.
Forcing many to flee for safety.
Back then, the safest route into Europe
went through Turkey.
From there, migrants could
cross into Greece by land
or take short boat rides across.
Hundreds of thousands of migrants
came in this way.
It was the largest migration wave
ever recorded in a single year
and the EU wasn’t prepared.
So in March of 2016, the EU
made a deal with Turkey.
Put simply, Turkey would hold back migrants
and take back any who made it to Greece.
In exchange, the EU would pay Turkey
€6 billion.
With this deal the EU moved its external borders
from here to here.
Essentially, outsourcing its border security
and legal responsibilities.
Human rights groups warned
the deal was “reckless” and “illegal”
and made migrants “subject to
human rights violations.”
Still, the deal went on to take effect and
migrant arrivals in Greece plummeted.
The deal was so effective in stopping
the flow of migrants
it soon took on a new geopolitical importance.
Over the years, Turkey learned it could threaten
to let migrants in
in exchange for more funds from the EU.
But it’s not just Turkey.
Europe has paid all these countries
to keep migrants from its borders.
You’ll notice they form a buffer around Europe
that stretches from Turkey to Morocco.
In many of these places, migrants are subject
to abuse and violence
including being pushed back to the conflict
areas they are trying to escape.
But Europe usually gets away
with pushing back migrants
because it happens here, far away
and out of sight.
And this gives all these countries leverage
and incentive to use migrants as pawns.
And that’s exactly what Lukashenko
is doingin Belarus
to try to get the EU to drop sanctions.
But it doesn't seem to be working.
After weeks of escalation, the EU adopted
yet another round of sanctions
and pressured airlines to cut off major air routes
from the Middle East to Minsk.
Belarus has finally admitted to moving migrants
to the border with Poland.
And has brought the migrants from the cold
camps to nearby warehouses for now.
But Lukashenko hasn't fully backed down yet.
In fact, he's still encouraging migrants to
cross into the EU.
And that’s because as long as the EU continues
to incentivize countries
to keep migrants away from its borders
leaders like Lukashenko
will find ways to exploit them.